have you seen the trend of women filming
men subtly looking at them in gyms it's
absolutely insane if I was a man I would
just go to an all-male gym if a man
checks me out in the gym I'm gonna smile
back or if I don't like him I'm just
gonna move away I'm not gonna whip out
my iPhone and then blast him on social
media it's like me too gone mad gone
crazy but it's funny because I'm
actually seeing the repercussions of
this I saw another video go viral of a
girl doing a squat with the rat and
she's stuck in that position and she
can't get back up and nobody is helping
her man isn't gonna risk everybody
laughing at him and calling him a creep
by actually going over to help her well
these are now the repercussions because
when a woman actually does need help men
won't help because they're terrified or
being blasted on social media for sexual
harassment and if I was a man I wouldn't
do it either I'd stay away from these
women they're crazy